I'm Dwight Howard, and my favorite
movie is Finding Nemo.
Man, I've probably seen it
200 times,
maybe more. 'Cause I used
to watch it all the time.
I can relate to the movie a lot
because my Dad is the same way
how Nemo's dad is.
MARLIN: Now, what's the one thing we have to
remember about the ocean?
-It's not safe.
-That's my boy.
It's a similar situation.
My mom, she lost seven kids.
And, um, I was one of the ones
that was not supposed to make it,
you know, also.
And I end up making it.
You know, I was, I'm
a blessing to be here.
That's why I can really relate
to that movie.
MARLIN: I will never let anything
happen to you... Nemo.
It's a genuine movie for me.
PRODUCER: You are Nemo!
(LAUGHING)
I'm not Nemo, I don't have
a little flipper.
(CHUCKLING)
And I love that movie because all
the different characters
and stuff like that.
DORY: Do you, do you, do you?
It's like, "Hello, my name is Bruce."
"Hi, Bruce."
BRUCE: Hello, my name is Bruce.
Hello, Bruce.
BRUCE: Fish are friends, not food.
Fish are friends, not food.
I'm in high school and I'm about
to enter the NBA draft
and, uh, I remember being at
the McDonald's game
and, you know, all the guys there
used to always make fun of me
'cause Finding Nemo
was my favorite movie.
And I would always say,
"Just keep swimming."
So anytime anybody saw me
and I was in a bad mood,
I wasn't smiling, they'd say,
"Dwight, just keep swimming."
And then everybody would say, "Just
keep swimming, just keep swimming."
♪ (SINGING) ♪
"What do you do? You swim!"
DORY: Oo, oo, I love to swim--
I would say, for me, coming
from where I came from,
you know, this, this small school.
You know, this atmosphere of love.
You know, where it was just us.
Then I go into this world
which, which is the NBA.
Once I stepped across that stage
and they called my name
and I put that hat on
to represent a team,
my whole life changed.
-ANNOUNCER 1: Dwight Howard.
-ANNOUNCER 2: A now 18-year-old
out of Southwest Atlanta
Christian High School--
You know, you're beating
yourselves up--
ANNOUNCER 3: Number one pick.
Congratulations, Dwight Howard--
It's really like stepping off
into the deep end of the ocean.
You go from this little platform
to this big world like Nemo did.
And here you have
a father who's basically--
he hasn't been anywhere either.
You know, and this
is his only son.
This is the only thing
that he has of his life.
You know, he's like, "I gotta
protect him at, at all costs."
Be safe.
DWIGHT:
Then you have a son who's like,
"I want to go out
and experience everything."
You know,
it really meant a lot to me.
And it kinda just helped me with
my situation at home with my Dad.
You know, and understanding him more
just from this movie.
You know, no matter
what happens in life,
no matter how far I stray away,
or whatever I do,
he's gonna always love me
and be there for me.
I'm Dwight Howard, and I love movies.